hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Robert Audi in his article the ethical
significance of cost-benefit analysis in
business and the professions notes that
for quite a few people cost benefit
analysis that is tallying up costs on
one side and benefits on another for
each option that you're looking at is
essentially equivalent to utilitarianism
and so they are liable to view it as
usable in ethics or as something that we
should reject depending on how they view
utilitarianism he is going to argue in
the article
that it's of use in other moral
theoretical approaches as well but he
begins by talking about utilitarianism
which makes perfect sense given that
um the the framework itself is going to
be uh understood in this this way and so
this is happening in the very first
section of the work and he's going to
say utilitarianism is in a good position
to use in illustrating this so this is
typically when we will bring cost
benefit analysis up whether it's in a
regular ethics class or a professional
ethics class of whatever sort it happens
to be for example business ethics which
is something that he's talking about
here
and he says that in its most common
hedonistic version
utilitarianism says in rough terms
there's only one thing good in itself
namely happiness uh including the
absence and presumably the reduction of
suffering and here's the the moral
principle
um the Supreme moral principle should be
that an act is right if and only if it
contributes at least as favorably to the
proportion of Happiness to unhappiness
in the relevant population as any
available alternative so what does it
actually mean well in practice you look
at the different options available
and you try to think about what the
outcomes are likely to be and you try to
choose the one that maximizes positive
outcomes and minimizes negative outcomes
for all the people who are affected and
there's a few other things in there in
the class classical utilitarian view
like each person's happiness counts just
as much as everybody else's
and so Audi says that you know a lot of
people would actually see this as he
says as a kind of Ethics by cost benefit
analysis so what is really distinctive
to utilitarianism what you're doing cost
benefit analyzes as an integral part of
deciding what the right thing to do is
the good thing to do given the different
Alternatives and you can do this for
specific cases and you can do this for
general
policies and you can do this even you
know thinking about human nature in
general and what it is that we tend to
like and dislike and make fairly General
statements about this and this is what
the classical utility utilitarian
philosophers like Jeremy Bentham and
John Stuart Mill and Henry Cedric and
others ended up doing
so how do we actually do this cost
benefit analysis he says well first we
assign numbers from negative to positive
to represent utilities utilities are the
just the numbers positive or negative
like a certain action could have
positive utility for me of let's say a
quanta of 10 when we tally it all up but
a negative outcome for everybody else
affected you know in a much greater
number and then we say okay we're not
going to do that sort of action so we
assign utility and uh he says we can
assign this in the form of quantities of
happiness or suffering so there's an
assumption there that we can actually
quantify happiness and suffering then we
have to think about the probabilities
and this is very important as well if my
doing an action that will actually
produce a great amount of positive
utility for a number of people has a
slight chance of also producing a
catastrophic effect that will produce a
lot more negative utility well we have
to figure out what that probability is
because if it's like you know an
infinitesimal amount that we're not
going to worry about it if it's ten
percent
that we are going to worry about it
right and we'll we'll consider that and
then he doesn't say this here but he
said it a little bit earlier we have to
think about the number of people who are
affected so if I can engage in an action
that has negative utility for me but
it's just kind of a mild irritant you
know it's not ruining my day and it can
make a whole bunch of other people happy
that whole bunch of other people you
know because each of them matters as
much as I do it's going to outweigh my
negative utility and with their positive
utility So This Is How We Do cost
benefit analyzes and you can do this in
terms of money as often is the proxy but
you can do it and also in terms of
quanta of pleasure or pain as Jeremy
Bentham attempts to do
we have all sorts of other ways of
trying to measure this as well but we do
have to assign numbers that's what's
really Central to this and then he's
going to talk about well what does a
utilitarian do you could think of it as
selecting the option with the highest
positive utility but what if you don't
actually have positive utility well then
you choose the one that has the lowest
negative utility if you're on a scale
you know however far far down the scale
is pick the best option best being the
one that you know is most likely to have
the better proportion of positive
outcomes over negative outcomes and he
gives you some examples here about like
a whistleblowing case a professional in
an architectural firm finds materials
being used which is not as good as the
contract calls for so we have a really
nice juicy and hopefully not too
commonplace sort of situation here and
you know he uh he says you know we can
actually tally this up you can read the
article itself to see how he does that
and the the two options are to divulge
the info Nation or just continue on with
business as usual and you know in this
case the architect actually has you know
two negative outcomes but finds that
um you know the continuing as usual is
preferable for them and we can say oh
that's that's not good that's going to
discourage whistleblowing right but we
can monkey around with the the numbers
and produce situations that are
conducive to promoting whistleblowing
right
now he does make two interesting points
that he wants to stress
um one is that the outcome values can
vary from option to option so for
example in the architect case
getting fired is one of the possible
negative outcomes right and it can be
valued in terms of
positive or negative utility in this
case negative utility differently in the
situation so getting fired because one
actually did the right thing might not
be as painful as just plain old getting
fired when you've been loyal in you know
quotes to the company loyal to the
company by not divulging that they're
actually doing the wrong thing so as he
says uh the context of the outcome may
affect its its value
and then he says a second thing is a
value can be assigned to anything its
users value as part of their happiness
so there may be some things that you
know we as you know sort of reasonably
well grounded morally developed
individuals myself that's that's kind of
negligible but if that figures into
somebody else's happiness
from utilitarian perspective you
actually need to take that into account
right and he says you know there's
there's constraints on this kind of
analysis
um you know we have to be considerate of
uh what is actually a a value in these
cases
um and he also goes on to say listen we
also do have to choose the lesser of two
evils in many cases we don't actually
need to introduce that as a rule because
that would make things a bit more
complex according to him so we go on and
we find that he says that and this shows
you the scope of utilitarianism these
examples that he's provided you know
medical examples architectural examples
show how utterly General the cost
benefit framework can be
you can use it for medical and moral
decisions for example as well as for
commercial uses in purely commercial
cases we substitute profit for happiness
or whatever value determines one
assignments of values to outcomes the
framework may be applied in the same way
right so there's
we can use this for just about anything
you could use this for personal
decisions you could use this for
governmental policy making that's why
we teach utilitarianism in basically
every ethics class it doesn't mean that
everybody has to become a utilitarian
but it's certainly a approach using cost
benefit analysis that is incredibly
widespread and for a lot of people quite
intuitive
now he goes on and he says two other
things that I think we need to take
stock of
one is and he uses the word appearance
here right which we should that should
raise some alarm bells for us he says
the procedure has the appearance of
being scientific except for the
assignment of value and that can be
scientific insofar as there are
objective measures of happiness and
suffering now is there really objective
measures of happiness and suffering
that's a big if there's a lot of
discussion out there about how this
could possibly work or not work but he
says that you know the appeal of
Hedonism and utilitarianism in this case
is a form of that is that it appears to
offer the possibility of an empirical
objective measure of value and you know
there's as I mentioned different ways of
doing this are conceptualizing this now
if we want it to be truly objective
truly scientific we have to do a lot of
research of course and this also offers
us the possibility of finding out that
we were were wrong in our original
assumptions or assessments about things
we have to actually go to people and say
well what do you like what do you
dislike right
the second thing that he says and I find
this a little bit unconvincing myself
but you'll have to think about this in
light of what you know about John Stuart
Mill's qualitative utilitarianism is uh
he says that you might think that a
qualitative utilitarianism like John
Stuart Mills cannot use the cost benefit
framework as described above because it
is quantitative but this would be a
mistake now just as a little refresher
John Stuart Mill says that there are not
just quantitative differences in
pleasures and pains but there are
qualitative some some things are better
to the extent that no amount of the
lower would substitute for the higher or
the loss or lack of the higher he's got
that famous phrase better to be Socrates
dissatisfied than a pig satisfied right
which gives you an idea about what he he
has in mind so I often frame this in
terms of beer versus books right it's
fun to drink beer tastes good you know
you can have a fun time at a party
because your social inhibitions have
been loosened up and you know it feels
kind of fun to to have that high at
least until you get too sick from it of
the alcohol but no amount of that
actually makes up for the pleasure that
a refined individual can find in a good
book right you can't you could pile up
cases and cases of beer and say here you
go it's all yours and that one book
outweighs if that's that's Mill's
position and he has a whole complex way
of describing how this works Audi says
well you can just assign a higher
quality to a higher quantity rather to
the recognized higher quality value and
he uses the example uh suppose that the
pleasures of watching a play by
Shakespeare are higher quality than
those of watching a new movie but the
quantities are assumed to be equal well
you just multi apply that quantitative
value by 1.5 in the case of the play and
he says Mill might have envisioned this
kind of strategy but I don't think that
that's what Mill has in mind so this
could still be a potential problem for
utilitarianism I will say this though
Mill thinks that if the pleasures are on
the same level right one kind of beer
versus another kind of beer or beer
versus wine or you know beer versus a
soda or coffee well then you can use
quantitative utilitarianism to talk
about it's only when there's radical
differences in quality that you're posed
with an issue so uh this is part of what
Audi says about utilitarianism in the
very start of this article
um he's he also talks about problems or
critiques that can be made but we're
we're going to put that off for a moment
it's enough just to understand
why utilitarianism is almost the same
thing it's you know in many people's
minds identical to cost benefit analysis
in ethics